[Applaudissements]
je suis là et d'avoir su cofondatrice et
directrice générale de petites voix
[Musique]
nous sommes dans l'atelier où les femmes
apprennent la couture industriels sont
ici six mois pour apprendre ce métier là
et ensuite on les aide pour trouver un
emploi
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très très diversifié on a
des femmes qui vient de convoquer
chasseurs soudain maroc haïti vietnam ou
le sri lanka bangladesh hennebert chine
québec montréal nous avons choisi de
deux d'offrir des services et de
programmes pour pouvoir aider ceux qui
savent pas où aller et qui reste
toujours robe oublier exclu marginalisés
dans leur foyer quand je suis arrivé ici
je parlais pas même prendre seulement
j'étais confronté à cette barrière de
notre connaissance du plan pour moi
c'était il faut absolument que
j'apprends la langue française il ya des
défauts qu'est ce que tu fais dès que le
coup est terminée j'ai décidé d'un faire
du bénévolat aller visiter les femmes
exclu qu'ils étaient malades dans leurs
maisons et tout ça je faisais un pierre
deux coups
[Musique]
je travaillais deux ans bénévolement
avec toutes les femmes à côte des neiges
qui venait chercher des denrées
alimentaires dans une banque alimentaire
des soeurs de sainte croix
on voulait absolument le vin autonome
pour pouvoir travailler et et douaniers
leur vie et on a fermé la banque
alimentaire et on a mis sur pied un
petit main
on l'a commencée dans une espèce de 500
pieds carrés et maintenant nouveau c'est
dans cette bâtisse au bout face à
l'ordre de 30 mille pieds carrés on
vient de travailler sur un projet un cpu
qui va être au service de tout le vin
qui vient à petit mais on a de la
cuisine plateau d'apprentissage de aide
cuisinière service à la clientèle
on a ajouté des cours d'eau français et
tout ça les doigts et 3 ça on a les
listes à temps des employeurs qui attend
pour la fin de la formation des femmes
ici pour qu'on puisse les envoyer dans
leur manufacture
[Applaudissements]
où à chaque matin je vends précis je
vois les femmes qui quittent et moins
spontanément comme ça merci de nous
donner la chance pour moi ça me donne la
satisfaction que je que je cherche dans
ma vie
[Musique]